vous présente souvent beaucoup de
produits et qui sont les produits les
plus performants la meilleure tablette
pour avoir le plus de performance la
meilleure tablette pour les
infographistes la meilleure tablette
pour en faire plein de choses là plus
endurante celtura plein de performance
mais qu'est ce qui se passe si vous
voulez acheter un produit vous voulez
pas un maximum de performances que vous
voulez juste avoir un bon produit pour
vous divertir pour aller surfer sur
internet pour regarder les réseaux
sociaux mais guère plus
si vous voulez pas une machine
extrêmement performante et vous voulez
un bon rapport qualité prix
alors là justement aujourd'hui j'ai un
produit qui est un peu atypique un
produit qui est même carrément atypique
et qui fait le job mais qui est vraiment
cet usage est d'avoir une tablette qui
marche qui est polyvalente permettra de
regarder plein de choses sur le web ce
soir d'une et flix de youtube tout ce
que vous voulez mais canal et compagnie
vous pouvez le faire sans aucun problème
vous allez pouvoir aller sur les réseaux
sociaux sans aucun problème mais vous
n'allez pas voir une bête de compet
cette tablette c'est elle la yoga
smarttags la yoga smartphones elle est
cool pourquoi parce qu'elle est peu de
sites
elle est compacte et comme ce qu'on peut
faire avec beaucoup de yoga on peut
faire des choses vraiment incroyables
avec même retourné au bout de son doigt
sans le faire tomber de préférence je
vous présente aujourd'hui sa 2 e gas
mart table qui a plein davantage qui
n'est pas un truc de fou mais qui par
contre ce sera vraiment vous surprendre
[Musique]
je sais pas vous mais moi j'utilise
beaucoup les tablettes pour le
divertissement souvent pour poser le
soir regarder une série naviguer sur
internet regarder youtube prendre un
moment tranquille à me détendre je suis
pas le roi de la productivité sur
tablette je fais plus sur l'ordinateur
ou alors quand j'ai besoin sur
smartphones et tablettes
pour moi c'est un petit peu l'entrejeu
c'est vraiment le moment cool zen à la
maison et cette tablette elle est
intéressante parce que justement elle
répond à cet usage à cet usage qui est
le mien je sais pas vous dites mon
commentaire quels usages vous avez de
votre tablette
est-ce que vous l'utilisez pour
travailler pour prendre des notes pour
aller en cours pour aller à la fac pour
aller au boulot vous travaillez dans les
transports en commun ou est ce que comme
moi la tablette vous l'utilisez
principalement pour vous divertir
connaît un petit moment mais tu es la
pause marie brassard dans un commentaire
c'est toujours intéressant de savoir
comment vous fonctionnez ce que vous
faites parce que j'ai toujours que ma
vision à moi point de vue utilisateur
pas forcément toujours là d'autres ça
c'est mon usage ça c'est ma façon de
faire ce que j'aime bien justement de
cette tablette c'est qu'elle me permet
de faire de différentes manières
en termes d'usagés prendre la tablette
et l'utiliser différentes manières je
peux la pause est comme ça sur un pied
vous avez système avec le trépied qui
marche bien en fait elle est positionnée
comme ça lorsqu'il est fermé
vous appuyez sur le bouton save au
louvre après vous la mettez comme vous
voulez première position vous la poser
sur une table pour regarder si vous
allez pouvoir venir l'apprendre comme ça
et ça vous allez remonter jusqu'au bout
alors ça c'était le visage qu'on va
avoir le moins avec votre tablette vous
la prenez vous la poser comme un cadre
photo vous l'apprenez que vous pouvez
accrocher quelque part pour que ce soit
beau vous la mettez sur un support
contre un mur et vous l'utiliser comme
une petite télé vous pouvez faire je
suis pas sûr qu est-ce qu on fasse le
plus mais si vous souhaitez vous pouvez
le faire mais pour moi l'usagé qu'on
vend le plus c'est de le fermer et de
tenir à la main comme ça comme un bon
vieux bouquin
pour pouvoir visionner tout ce que vous
voulez alors comme un ebook pour
imaginer par exemple l'utiliser pour
pouvoir lire des bouquins
si vous le souhaitez ça marche très très
bien failli cool mais vous avez un petit
format un peu plus arrondies son côté on
a une bonne prise en main on à côté
qu'il n'est pas glissant derrière on la
trappe c'est assez douce est assez
agréable à tenir le fait que vous ayez
ce côté là qu'ils soient un peu plus
rond et ça s'améliore significativement
l'expérience pour utiliser la tablette
très facilement pu regarder du contenu
multimédia en obtenant directement dans
ma main que vous teniez à l'horizontale
ou que vous reteniez à la verticale dans
tous les cas c'est vraiment pratique
avec certaines marques et satan produits
à savoir ce qu'a réellement voulu faire
la marque air qui elle se destine et
qu'est ce qu'on peut voir réellement
faire là pour le coup c'est clair de
c'est clair c'est clair c'est limpide
c'est un produit qui est destiné
réellement pour le multimédia
ce grand écran marche écran de 10,1
pouces surtout les deux haut parleurs
haut parleurs ici haut parleurs là ce
sont des haut parleurs jbl 2 x 2 watts
avec du dolby atmos ça marche bien sûr
tout ça marche très très bien vous avez
beaucoup de son expérience multimédia
est vraiment excellente aux notions qui
est vraiment qualité c'est fort lorsque
vous pousse à fond c'est fort c'est très
très fort c'est vraiment agréable et
surtout il ya une vraie immersion une
vraie spatialisation du son
on a beau qu'un produit qui remplit
parfaitement sa mission et si toutefois
vous voulez vous isolez mettre un casque
et bien vous pouvez le faire vous avez
une prise jack qui est juste là vous
venez brancher un casque ça marche prise
jack sortie oui mais aussi entrer ça
fait micro donc si vous les brancher un
micro casque comme des usages de gaming
pourquoi pas vous pouvez faire alors
attention attention attention je vous
parle de gagner oui mais attention il
n'y a pas beaucoup de performances là
dessus parce qu'on tombe sur un dragon
439 c'est pas énorme
on n'a pas une machine extrêmement
puissante on a deux configurations 3
giga de ram 32 go de stockage ou alors 4
gigas de ram 64 giga de stockage dans
les deux cas extensible grâce à une
carte micro sd vous allez venir branché
ici insérez plutôt directement ici à
l'arrière jusqu'à 256 giga donc voyez
c'est pas complètement dingue
la ram c'est de la lp ddr3 c'est pas un
truc de fou ça marche c'est cohérent
c'est correct mais pour faire tourner
des petits jeux de dupes les stores pour
faire tourner des jeux pas trop
gourmands pour un usage vous d une fois
de plus multimédia petit divertissement
on a ici une dalle ups un écran lcd de
10,1 pouces full hd 1920 par 1200 mais
ce qui est vachement bien c'est qu'on
est une machine qui est très autonome
avec une très grosse batterie de 7000
millan perreur 7000 millan terreur vous
êtes tranquille vous pouvez le garder
suffisamment longtemps
lenovo nous annonce 10 heures
d'autonomie en lecture vidéo je pense
que là dessus vous êtes vraiment
tranquille vous le recharger rapidement
en usb c'est d'un point de vue purement
autonomie ça tient la route on va
retrouver à l'avant une caméra de 5
mégapixels pour déverrouiller très
facilement grâce à la reconnaissance de
votre visage et à l'arrière une caméra
de 8 mégapixels avec l'autofocus c'est
pas une tablette qui est fait pour faire
des photos vous pouvez le faire pour
l'heure quelques souvenirs si l'occasion
se présente mais c'est pas du tout fait
pour faire simple donc n'allez pas vous
poser la question de la voir pour capter
des souvenirs
vous pourriez franchement déçu non le
focus là-dessus vraiment fait du point
de vue du divertissement d'ailleurs
c'est un des arguments que vous avez au
niveau de votre tablette
regardez c'est écrit ici le yoga smart
tab with google assistant donc l'idée
c'est de pouvoir l'utiliser comme
n'importe quelle tablette intelligent
que vous allez pouvoir poser à un
endroit lorsque vous ne regardez pas du
contenu vous et pouvoir l'utiliser comme
un cadre photo numérique vous allez
pouvoir l'utiliser pour poser toutes vos
questions à google alors on n'est pas
sur un google est up mais en tout cas
vous pouvez poser toutes vos questions à
google docs et google calendar docs et
google c'est ça ok google ça marche bien
étant plus que vous avez trois micros
qui sont positionnées sur notre appareil
qui vous permettent de capter du son à
360 degrés et même si vous êtes à
l'autre bout de la pièce donc centaines
d'usagers
c'est bien ça me permet d'interagir
facilement d'avoir les mains libres de
la pause et pourquoi pas lorsque vous
cuisinez vous la posez un emploi vous
avez les mains dans le pétrin faites ce
que vous voulez que vos mains sales
blancs regarde pas voulu poser vos
questions et elle va pouvoir vous
affichez les réponses très facilement ça
c'est vraiment les usages majeur de la
tablette multimédia divertissement qui
va vous rendre service
grâce à google assistant on est donc sur
un produit familial facile à utiliser on
tourne et c'est sur un android 9 pie ix
à part entre eux a raconté ça marche
bien vous avez votre tiroir avec toutes
vos applications qui se situe en bas
vous appuyez vous revenez vous avez une
navigation à geste vous pouvez obtenir
appuyé sur le bouton ici ici moi je me
retrouve sur youtube vous allez pouvoir
trouver des informations très facilement
vous avez un accès rapide à tous vos
paramètres bourse une tablette android
jusque là ça marche il n'y a pas grand
chose à raconter là dessus ici vous
allez pas utiliser un casque sans fil un
casque bluetooth vous avez du bluetooth
4 points 2 c'est vraiment pas lui c'est
ce que je vais venir vous conseiller ce
que je vous conseille vraiment au niveau
multimédia c'est vraiment usages haut
parleurs lorsque vous êtes tranquille
vous pouvez mettre du son sans aucun
problème et si vous voulez vous isolez
vous brancher un petit casque ici en
jack ça marche bien c'est vraiment cool
moi je trouve vraiment bien cette
tablette et elle saura vraiment faire ce
pour quoi elle est faite c'est à dire
pour l'aspect multimédia pour l'aspect
domestique pour l'aspect familial
ne cherchez pas à lui faire faire ce
qu'elle ne sait pas faire elle ne s'est
pas être hyper performante elle ne saura
pas faire du multitâche
elle ne saura pas faire des choses
complexes mais pour des petits usage au
quotidien à la maison elle ira
parfaitement bien à une fois de plus je
vous le dis je le dis et je redis pour
le multimédia ça c'est vraiment cool ça
se positionne partout facilement grâce à
son petit pied intégré cette coulée en
face on a vraiment une sensation de
robusta gré en passe bien j'ai un truc
ça risque de casser bout d'un moment il
ya un côté un peu top pas du tout je
trouve ça cool sur sa solide je lui fais
confiance je
trouve ça vraiment bien je pense qu'une
fois de plus les nouveaux a fait un beau
boulot ars dans cette idée de yoga dans
l'idée de on se plie on se plie tous les
côtés or ici on plie pas grand chose on
y a juste payé ça mais ça suffit pour
être dans la gamme yoga on a un produit
qui est vraiment bien pour le multimédia
pour garder vos films séries et tout ce
que vous voulez ça c'est cool a vous de
me dire ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire comment vous la trouvez
cette aiguille yoga smart ah ben moi je
la trouve cool et je vous dis une fois
de plus son côté multimédia s'il voulait
pas mettre trop d'argent je vous la
conseille alors qu'en est il justement
au niveau du tarif
monsieur grand une fois de plus sa
sortie sa feuille avec son tarif vous
avez donc de config 3 + 32 go de
stockage à 249 c'est parce que je vous
conseille moi ce que je vous conseille
c'est la config au dessus 4 64 32 vous
risquez d'être limité il ya déjà le
poids de l'eau est si vous mettez
quelques applications dans pour un peu
que vous télécharger des films un peu de
musique vous êtes tout de suite bloqués
vous allez le regretter
vous rajoutez 50 euros vous arrivez à
299 4 64 et là vous avez un produit qui
viennent en plus que vous trouver
quelques promos en ligne d'ailleurs si
ce projet vous intéresse je vous ai mis
des liens en bas dans la description
perso je trouve cool
a vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
donc retrouver ses deux gas masta ace
qu'elle peut vous tente et n'oubliez pas
répondre à la question vous est posée au
début quels usages vous avez avec votre
tablette
marc m'a tout ça en grand commentaires
quand un loupé on se retrouve dès demain
pour aussi bien par les textes de marie
à demain
[Musique]